et après monsieur le sénateur cantal à
savoir qui avait raison qu'ils avaient
tort sur la deuxième vague
je laisse les français qui regardent
public sénat cherchez la dernière fois
que j'étais en train de répondre à ce
micro dans cet hémicycle c'était il ya
quelques jours je crois que l'une des
dernières interventions j'avais fait
monsieur le rapporteur bas s'en souvient
parce qu'il était d'accord avec moi
c'était pour demander aux sénateurs de
droite et de gauche d'avoir la
responsabilité de ne pas voter un
amendement déposé par tous les groupes
de sénateurs visant à empêcher le
gouvernement de fermer des
établissements recevant du public et
autorisant donc de fait c'était il ya
quelques jours la réouverture des
discothèques à marseille des restaurants
à lyon des bars à saint-etienne à telle
enseigne qu une deuxième délibération a
été demandée dans l'urgence par les
sénateurs voyant l'erreur qui a été
commise donc s'il vous plaît pas de son
[Musique]